Plus
[Music]
for
yeah
so
uh I I have
to physically but of course
energetically organize my body
okay
so can't be up here you see like I'm
just going to somebody grabs me and I
let him grab my wrist that's not what's
happening okay so energetically pull
internally I forming the tonden field
okay and
now uh and you can see some things that
happen you pay attention because this
energy is being directed down you pay
attention and I'm dropping I don't know
if you can see it I can feel
it a little slower okay I let him I
ground it keep going
more and you see my things are moving
swelling okay and then scanning for
tension letting it go and now what I'm
going to do is move my
hands to turn that tand de
it's not just that I'm turning my tanden
I turn pushes I turn my tongen that's
not just what's happening my my
hands turn the
tongen
boom
okay I'm to turn keep turning
it who turn it the other
way
Turn It
Forward there's the settling turn the
hand turns the tong in so
no
turns turn it the other
way we
off
Boom turn
turns turns the
tund
settle
turns my hand turns my
Center
there
go
off
all right and so inside that energetic
work you have uh a active so your Coq
and you have your passive your
[Music]
IP so you have your projection but
nothing
changes and you're
adhesion w
and so when you do
that more and
more take
out your ego tripartite need for tension
here take out more
it's just
relaxed everything's
inside even
here trust the
adhesion
you do a m is that the t is rotating in
two different directions on each version
by two different means okay uh and
because of the concentric nature between
um your energetic component and your
Marshall
component if you pay
attention he's got a fullon grip it's
the same exact grip he had at the
beginning you see so if we came
back and he
grip if I wasn't strong enough to just
peel that off there I'm not going to
peel it off here
but you get lazy and you try and do it
but if you pay attention you're T in
stop
turning okay this is this is the outward
spiral and on a Mot you do the inward
spiral okay so you're here and you got
one more
turn to push to the Elbow get out of the
habit of using that outer
deltoid well you can't pull this off
you do one more turn enter in you push
through that
grip keep your grip tight okay I can't
peel that off but I can turn and then
drrive through and you're
out so I'll do it a little smoother and
you can see how I do that one more
turn and my goal is to turn my
tonden
we
work you you're not going to do that but
you're going to
enter you see and you're in that same
position and now you can use that
hand so don't combine the uran word on
the mot you just hold you enter the bo
and it's
out and now you pay attention to this
hand as I
enter here is how I'm turning the tanden
field this time this
way enter the
bar
out
this way you don't ever overd dominate
on
this
turn
clean up your Tes